It turns out that we're fighting one of the most evolutionarily-conserved
learning processes currently known in science,
one that's conserved
back to the most basic nervous systems known to man.
This reward-based learning process
is called positive and negative reinforcement,
and basically goes like this.
We see some food that looks good,
our brain says, "Calories! ... Survival!"
We eat the food, we taste it --
it tastes good.
And especially with sugar,
our bodies send a signal to our brain that says,
"Remember what you're eating and where you found it."
We lay down this context-dependent memory
and learn to repeat the process next time.
See food,
eat food, feel good,
repeat.
Trigger, behavior, reward.
Simple, right?
Well, after a while, our creative brains say,
"You know what?
You can use this for more than just remembering where food is.
You know, next time you feel bad,
why don't you try eating something good so you'll feel better?"
We thank our brains for the great idea,
try this and quickly learn
that if we eat chocolate or ice cream when we're mad or sad,
we feel better.
Same process,
just a different trigger.
Instead of this hunger signal coming from our stomach,
this emotional signal -- feeling sad --
triggers that urge to eat.
Maybe in our teenage years,
we were a nerd at school,
and we see those rebel kids outside smoking and we think,
"Hey, I want to be cool."
So we start smoking.
The Marlboro Man wasn't a dork, and that was no accident.
See cool,
smoke to be cool,
feel good. Repeat.
Trigger, behavior, reward.
And each time we do this,
we learn to repeat the process
and it becomes a habit.
So later,
feeling stressed out triggers that urge to smoke a cigarette
or to eat something sweet.
Now, with these same brain processes,
we've gone from learning to survive
to literally killing ourselves with these habits.
Obesity and smoking
are among the leading preventable causes of morbidity and mortality in the world.
So back to my breath.
What if instead of fighting our brains,
or trying to force ourselves to pay attention,
we instead tapped into this natural, reward-based learning process ...
but added a twist?
What if instead we just got really curious
about what was happening in our momentary experience?
I'll give you an example.
In my lab,
we studied whether mindfulness training could help people quit smoking.
Now, just like trying to force myself to pay attention to my breath,
they could try to force themselves to quit smoking.
And the majority of them had tried this before and failed --
on average, six times.
Now, with mindfulness training,
we dropped the bit about forcing and instead focused on being curious.
In fact, we even told them to smoke.
What? Yeah, we said, "Go ahead and smoke,
just be really curious about what it's like when you do."
And what did they notice?
Well here's an example from one of our smokers.
She said, "Mindful smoking:
smells like stinky cheese
and tastes like chemicals,
YUCK!"
Now, she knew, cognitively that smoking was bad for her,
that's why she joined our program.
What she discovered just by being curiously aware when she smoked
was that smoking tastes like shit.
(Laughter)
Now, she moved from knowledge to wisdom.
She moved from knowing in her head that smoking was bad for her
to knowing it in her bones,
and the spell of smoking was broken.
She started to become disenchanted with her behavior.
Now, the prefrontal cortex,
that youngest part of our brain from an evolutionary perspective,
it understands on an intellectual level that we shouldn't smoke.
And it tries its hardest to help us change our behavior,
to help us stop smoking,
to help us stop eating that second, that third, that fourth cookie.
We call this cognitive control.
We're using cognition to control our behavior.
Unfortunately,
this is also the first part of our brain
that goes offline when we get stressed out,
which isn't that helpful.
Now, we can all relate to this in our own experience.
We're much more likely to do things like yell at our spouse or kids
when we're stressed out or tired,
even though we know it's not going to be helpful.
We just can't help ourselves.
When the prefrontal cortex goes offline,
we fall back into our old habits,
which is why this disenchantment is so important.
Seeing what we get from our habits
helps us understand them at a deeper level --
to know it in our bones
so we don't have to force ourselves to hold back
or restrain ourselves from behavior.
We're just less interested in doing it in the first place.
And this is what mindfulness is all about:
Seeing really clearly what we get when we get caught up in our behaviors,
becoming disenchanted on a visceral level
and from this disenchanted stance, naturally letting go.
This isn't to say that, poof, magically we quit smoking.
But over time, as we learn to see more and more clearly
the results of our actions,
we let go of old habits and form new ones.
The paradox here
is that mindfulness is just about being really interested
in getting close and personal
with what's actually happening in our bodies and minds
from moment to moment.
This willingness to turn toward our experience
rather than trying to make unpleasant cravings go away as quickly as possible.
And this willingness to turn toward our experience
is supported by curiosity,
which is naturally rewarding.
What does curiosity feel like?
It feels good.
And what happens when we get curious?
We start to notice that cravings are simply made up of body sensations --
oh, there's tightness, there's tension,
there's restlessness --
and that these body sensations come and go.
These are bite-size pieces of experiences
that we can manage from moment to moment
rather than getting clobbered by this huge, scary craving
that we choke on.
In other words, when we get curious,
we step out of our old, fear-based, reactive habit patterns,
and we step into being.
We become this inner scientist
where we're eagerly awaiting that next data point.
Now, this might sound too simplistic to affect behavior.
But in one study, we found that mindfulness training
was twice as good as gold standard therapy at helping people quit smoking.
So it actually works.
And when we studied the brains of experienced meditators,
we found that parts of a neural network of self-referential processing
called the default mode network
were at play.
Now, one current hypothesis is that a region of this network,
called the posterior cingulate cortex,
is activated not necessarily by craving itself
but when we get caught up in it, when we get sucked in,
and it takes us for a ride.
In contrast, when we let go --
step out of the process
just by being curiously aware of what's happening --
this same brain region quiets down.
Now we're testing app and online-based mindfulness training programs
that target these core mechanisms
and, ironically, use the same technology that's driving us to distraction
to help us step out of our unhealthy habit patterns
of smoking, of stress eating and other addictive behaviors.
Now, remember that bit about context-dependent memory?
We can deliver these tools to peoples' fingertips
in the contexts that matter most.
So we can help them
tap into their inherent capacity to be curiously aware
right when that urge to smoke or stress eat or whatever arises.
So if you don't smoke or stress eat,
maybe the next time you feel this urge to check your email when you're bored,
or you're trying to distract yourself from work,
or maybe to compulsively respond to that text message when you're driving,
see if you can tap into this natural capacity,
just be curiously aware
of what's happening in your body and mind in that moment.
It will just be another chance
to perpetuate one of our endless and exhaustive habit loops ...
or step out of it.
Instead of see text message, compulsively text back,
feel a little bit better --
notice the urge,
get curious,
feel the joy of letting go
and repeat.
Thank you.
(Applause)